a disturbing story out of the west  valley a mother of three accused of  leaving her kids unattended in a room  and duct taping the door shut while she  went to the store good afternoon and  thank you so much for joining us here at  four i'm christian costas and i'm brian  loftis kirsten off today taremi beverly  now facing child abuse charges  in the january incident an arrest report  was obtained by the i-team  left the kids in a bedroom with access  to a bathroom a downstairs neighbor had  reported a leak  and that's when police say they found  the children with the bathtub  overflowing  a one-year-old found sleeping on the wet  floor now it took police officers  multiple times to wake the toddler  the report went on to say that beverly  told police she left  to get candy a prelim hearing is set for  the 10th of may you can find  the full report as well as helpful  resources for parents  at 8newsnow.com